سالنا الناس برايك هل الابتسامه فن يحتاج
الى التدريب شوف شو اللي قاله
[موسيقى]
لا
انها من رب العالمين
الابتسامه حسب نفسيه البني ادم
لازم يكون الانسان مبتسم حتى لو ايش ما
كان يعني الابتسامه لازم تكون لازم تكون
انه الانسان من طبيعته مبتسم لان حديث
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم تبسمك فيها وجه
اخيك صدقه فلو مبتسم البشوش هو من اجمل
الوجوه لا الابتسامه بتيجي مع الانسان من
داخله الانسان المبتسم الضحوه دائما انسان
مبشر دائما يكون في الخير وفي كل شيء
لا يحتاج انها تكون فن او تدريب
يعني اكيد لا لانه الابتسامه ربانيه
والابتسامه اكيد لازم تكون موجوده على كل
بني ادم الابتسامه زي ما قال الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم
ما بدها تدريب ولا بدها
انك تقعد تمارس عليها لا ابدا الابتسامه
بتطلع من القلب وبتدل على ايجابيه الشخص
ويعني سعادته بالحياه فما بحسها هي بدها
تدريب قد ما هي بس بدها مجهود صغير لحتى
تطلع الابتسامه للعالم يعني بالنسبه الي
الابتسامه هي كل شيء يعني مرات بدك تتدرب
على الابتسامه لانه ما بتعرف متى بتكون
مضطرت تبتسم بوجه حدا محتاج هاي الابتسامه
فا وبنفس الوقت فن مضطر تتدرب عليه
[تصفيق]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات